[Applause]
[Applause]
hey guys it's me Peter Brown reading
Justin Clark's review of Mario Tennis
aces when the credits rolled on Mario
Tennis aces adventure mode I vowed to
never laugh at a tennis player having an
ugly male down on the court I had felt
the volcanic surge of adrenaline that
comes when a rally has gone too long
I knew the sense of high alert while
trying to suss out which corner of the
court an opponent is going to attack
next
I have spliced and invented new curse
words to mutter when a ball goes out of
bounds
offbeat stages and creative use of
characters from the Mario vs. ensure
that you'll never lose sight of simply
having fun but don't let that adorable
exterior trick you
Asus takes it's unorthodox tennis very
seriously
[Applause]
Mario Tennis has renewed vigor is driven
by a suite of new mechanics that force
you to make pivotal risk/reward
decisions special shots are now tied to
a meter that fills a little with every
shot fired back of your opponent more so
if you're able to charge your swing
ahead of time once the energy meter is
at least 1/3 full a bar landing on your
side of the court will be forecast by a
glowing star initiating a special swing
while on a star activates a first-person
view that lets you aim a powerful zone
shop and when the meter is completely
full you can unleash your character's
special shot and while specials don't
unleash the kalakeya of effects they
didn't we use Mario Tennis ultra smash
they do fire a lightning fastball that
requires exacting maneuvers to return
without incurring any harm to your
racket destroy your collection of
rackets during a match and you lose
holding the r button slows down time at
the cost of meter allowing you to stroll
over and hit hard-to-reach shots or gain
a slight advantage when returning racket
breaking balls alternatively a new dodge
mechanic called trickshot allows you to
tilt the right stick in the direction of
an incoming shot and if timed right leap
across the court and smack it away at
high speed you can get away with basic
shots during simple matches but in
advanced matches the exchange of powered
up strikes feels like a breathless
symphony that requires you to be at the
top of your game and on top of your
options
even veterans of the series have a
little bit of a learning curve to
overcome but aces Adventure mode does a
good job of both entertaining you and
teaching you how and when to use your
new tools the story itself is ridiculous
but ridiculous in that very specific
quirky way intend Oh has been getting
away with for decades during the
mushroom kingdoms annual tennis
tournament and evil tennis racket yes
really named Lucien takes possession of
Luigi and flies off to find five power
stones that will help him take over the
world instead of settling for a
revolving door of opponents along the
way you're challenged to utilize aces
new mechanics in a range of unusual
scenarios an average stage might simply
challenge you to keep a rally going for
a certain length of time but bosses and
puzzle stages require a greater level of
ingenuity you have to figure out how to
disable protective barriers earning
enough energy to perform a zone shot an
aim at the right part of the court to
inflict damage bosses also initiate
hurdling challenges mid-match that
reward precise use of you're leaping
trickshot a venture mode mixes up your
objectives from one stage to the next to
ensure you're never simply going through
the motions to progress
[Music]
asus is more difficult in devious than
you might expect especially in the
latter half of adventure mode though not
required grinding through matches can't
improve your chances on the court but
win or lose urine experience points for
every match played allowing you to
improve Mario's speed power and agility
over time but no matter how much XP you
earn the only way to make it to the end
of aces campaign is to master its unique
tennis mechanics those who persevere
will find themselves better equipped and
prepared to face anything the other
modes have to offer outside of adventure
mode you'll find a rather plain
assortment of activities a bracket based
tournament mode exhibition matches
against the computer or another friend
online modes and the ability to play
doubles matches which can turn into
downright Anarchy before you know it one
surprising this step in the package is
swing mode where players can swing joy
Kahn's like proper tennis rackets
similar to we sports tennis at first it
seems odd that this control scheme is
isolated to a specific mode but within a
minute or two it's obvious why
playing with joy Kahn's feels too
imprecise and even just executing a
simple backhand was a twitchy comedy of
errors it's too bad that the motion
controls seem to fall apart so easily
but considering that and it's probably
best that the option is siloed away odds
are most players will spend the majority
of their time the long run playing aces
online an experience that can be pretty
hit or miss depending on how you're
matched up the lack of stat tracking
means that you have no way to visually
gauge how skilled your opponent may be
prior to accepting a match and as such
lopsided matches are commonplace casual
players do have the option of limiting
matches to simple gameplay which removes
special mechanics and hazard type stages
from the mix even without the
exhilaration of special shots there's
still something relaxing about
occasionally fooling around with a
no-frills version of Mario Tennis
however even this approach winds up
feeling flawed due to the lack of
options that are freely configurable in
local multiplayer matches including the
number of racquets per player the type
of stages you play on and the duration
of a battle online free play matches are
also locked into tiebreaker rules for
points instead of full-blown tennis sets
which goes a little too far in whittling
back the game's death tournament mode is
even more limited doing away with the
option to play using simple rules there
also isn't any incentive for success no
rewards waiting at the end of a brutal
five match gauntlet and frankly people
who persevere deserves something that
may change in the coming months with
multiple character slots marked as being
reserved
for participating in tournaments every
month but as of the time of this writing
even that comes off as the smallest
token still it speaks volumes that even
these limitations don't entirely dampen
my enthusiasm for aces the tetris effect
is in full swing here days after the
credits rolled I still crave the
satisfying thwack from a Power Shot
mentally replay matches and imagine how
I might do things differently given a
bit more focus and know how Mario Tennis
Aces does what the series has done best
and for the most part improves what it's
rarely gotten right before
[Music]
[Music]